richard is with us in pennsylvania
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show Richard
hi thanks for taking the call
sure what's up just a question an
elderly gentleman who's a friend of the
family once to actually give me his
house that he's owned his whole life and
he no longer lives in Wow
yeah I'm kind of like you know really
nervous about the whole thing but the
problem is Amin baby step two and I have
$15,000 in debt and it needs a lot of
repairs is it habitable not at the time
no so you'd have to do repairs in order
to live in it yeah Wow what do you make
$32,000 a year thirty-three thousand a
year okay yeah and what is this how
she's giving you worth as is alright
maybe fifteen with the property I'm
gonna guess okay and so it needs thirty
forty thousand dollars worth of work um
I don't really know I know
the roofs okay it needs like a wall tore
out and replaced but why I'm like not
happen right now it's wrong with it that
won't allow you to live in it
he hasn't been in eight years and there
was an animal inside and it tore apart
the all the carpeting and there's feces
feces everywhere and that's it some mold
a little bit of mold issues in the attic
and then the one wall had rotted out a
little bit with a chimney leaked okay
what is his expectation that you're
gonna do with the house if he gives it
to you he does he does he require that
you fix it up and move in it I think
that's what he wants me to do yeah yeah
okay what we're we're in Pennsylvania is
this house uh it's near Dubois so
small-town or what very small T I'd like
maybe 10,000 people okay in the area
Punxsutawney Phil close to that out you
near the ground on its it sounds like a
very nice idea doesn't sound like much
of a house is that a mean thing to say
no no no I mean even fixed up this is
not exactly a palace no is the
neighborhood bad or it's just rule all
right Earl yeah okay it's a nice
neighborhood I mean okay all right huh
I just don't I don't like crazy cuz I
think I'm going crazy I'm like I don't
know cuz I'm in debt it's not you know I
don't really have the money to put into
it but I also don't have a house I mean
currently I'm just renting yeah what if
you told him you could take it but you
can't work on it until you get out of
that and it just sits just sits there
yeah I guess I could do that it's been
sitting there for awhile we can do a
little better job of boarding it up and
keep the keep the critters out of it
right but yeah and let's just board it
up real tight and sit on it until until
you get out of debt and are able to save
some money to begin to work on it right
then you can work an extra job and you
know clear up your dad and then work an
extra job and pile up some money to do
the renovation if it was completely
renovated and you were debt-free is this
where you'd want to live I don't know
honestly no okay I yeah I actually have
I don't know if I even want to live in
the state forever so yeah well I don't
know that you have to stay forever
forever is a long time but I'm just
saying for the next three years or five
years is this where you'd want to live I
could for three years definitely I mean
because I think I think I think what you
might do is sit down and just have a
discussion with him just go there's a
lot of work to be done as you know it's
all the pieces it's a wonderful gift I
don't want to seem ungrateful because
I'm not
I'm very grateful there's two things I
need to have your your blessing on one
is is that I'm not going to do the work
for a while
and two is that after I do the work and
move in it I may sell it then after that
and I want that I want you to be okay
with that and if he's okay with both of
those things then that could be your
plan that you you know don't do anything
to it now say get out of debt save up
the money fix it up move in it live in
it a year or two and then sell it okay
cuz you make you know you might make 50
grand doing that right yeah if you fixed
it up you might only handyman myself
well I mean my point is though that you
know you spend the money on it and you
pay cash for all the repairs and
gradually right and you and you fix the
thing up and doll it up even if you have
someone do the work that's fine and then
put it on the market and sell it a year
or two later and you know get a little
bit a little living time out of it and
it you know it's kind of a side project
for you to make some money on that could
work out fine for you that'd be an okay
way to go at the thing or just saying
you know it's a wonderful offering thank
you but I really I'm not in the position
to take advantage of it right now
because I'm in debt I don't they might
have fix it up and I'm sorry I can't
take it and just turn it turn down the
gift that's the other option either ones
okay there's nothing wrong with either
one it's not like somebody's giving you
a $200,000 house here I mean he's giving
you a shanty and so it's just got to be
you know anywhere in America today that
you can get a house for $15,000 we're
calling that not much of a house okay so
it's okay though we could be fixed up
and it could be fine and I'm not being
snot snobby about it it's just a matter
of you know just looking at what we're
dealing with